there'll be 13 european teams at this
world cup more than any other continent
france the defending champions and many
people's favorites with the likes of
killian and bappe and karen benzema but
no team has won back-to-back world cups
since brazil in 1962.
germany always a force to be reckoned
with well except for the last world cup
where they didn't manage to make it out
of the group stage they've won the
tournament four times and we're the
first team to qualify after the host
qatar they've got a tough draw though
going head-to-head with 2010 champions
spain and what's shaping up to be the
standout tie of the group stage can
cristiano ronaldo finally get his hands
on the trophy it's likely his last
chance to add to the european cup he won
with portugal back in 2016. like
portugal poland got into the tournament
via the playoffs and they too have a
pretty formidable start by the name of
robert lewandowski fifa's player of the
year for 2021. what about england they
haven't won since 1966 but under manager
gareth southgate they reached the semis
last time and were runners-up at the
euros last year they're in the same
group as wales who were in their first
world cup in 64 years watch out for
their main man gareth bale belgium also
very much a team to watch out for kevin
de bruyne's side topped the fifa world
rankings for over three years and were
only recently overtaken by brazil and
netherlands they could be on the shout
they're back in the tournament after
missing out in 2018. only eight
countries have ever won the world cup
five of them have come from europe